Hillary Clinton was just giving a talk
at the Institute for Global politics and
she was Fielding questions I suppose and
one Brave young man stood up to question
Hillary's warmongering can you please
make a statement about President Joe
Biden's speech this is a clearly
warmongering speech President Joe Biden
is calling for a hundred billion do of
funding for Israel Taiwan and Ukraine
and we're supposed to just bundle these
together and protect like we're going to
rush to World War II and we're all just
going to let Hillary rodam Clinton sit
here I'm sorry you know this is not this
is not the way to have a conversation if
you want have a conversation you're
welcome to come talk to me after here
okay right you're going you're going to
you're going to wait for me right please
I don't I do not believe you I listen to
you and I will respond to you I do not
believe you respectfully I do not
believe you fact of the matter is that
the American people's voice are what
need to be heard
because because our president is not
speaking for the American people and
neither are you that's your opinion
that's your opinion yes that's my
opinion well then sit down we've heard
your opinion thank you very much for
once I actually believe Hillary this
this man seems incredulous that Hillary
will stick around and wait for him
afterwards I think she's going to wait
for him I think she's this man is
definitely going to see Hillary again
you know I'm really sorry to hear about
this man's imminent suicide seems like a
nice enough fella a little bit excitable
a little bit eccentric
but she they're going to talk soon and
there might not be much talking actually
in that
conversation I sometimes wonder how I've
survived Hillary all these years I think
it's because I've I've mentioned this on
the show before but not recently Hillary
and I are cousins
in-law on my great-grandmother's side on
my paternal great-grandmother's side uh
we've got I've got a relative who
married into the rodom family and so
Hillary is a sort of cousin of mine and
I I think it's merely because of family
ties that she has not just shown up yet
in the middle of the night you know with
a mustache on or maybe just a full ski
mask and just put that pillow over my
head snuffed out me in this entire show
thankful I'm grateful to Hillary for
that uh this man however does not seem
to have any ties of kinship with Hillary
and so I'm not sure that be so lucky in
any case what does this mean here right
now go to ziprecruiter.com we do things
differently here at the daily wire we
host several of the top news podcasts in
the world we launched a chocolate
company overnight we just took Disney
head on by releasing 100 episodes of
kids content it takes very specific
people with very specific skills
acquired over a very long career to make
the daily wire what it is how do we find
and hire these people with zip recruiter
that's how zip recruiter makes your
whole hiring process faster and easier
their powerful technology works for you
to identify people whose skills and
experience match your job Z recruiter
saves you Time by letting you easily
invite top candidates to apply for your
job so they're more likely to apply
sooner Z recruiter is trusted by over
3.8 million businesses for their hiring
needs make a positive impact on your
hiring future with zi recruiter four out
of five employers who post on zip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day go to ziprecruiter.com to
try ZipRecruiter for free that is
ziprecruiter.com KL e s zip recruiter
the smartest way to hire right now go to
Ru greens.com you know you know I'm not
I'm not a dog person but I am a people
person and I care for all living
creatures so I send my stepbrother Ruff
greens for his little Australian
Shepherd I the miniature Australian
shepherd and uh CU I I I don't trust my
step brother to get him the good stuff
and Ruff greens is the absolute best
stuff out there naturopathic doctor
Dennis black the founder of rough greens
is focused on improving the health of
every dog in America dog food may as
well be considered dead food since it
contains very little nutritional value
let rough greens bring your dogs food
back to life rough greens is a
supplement that contains all the
necessary vitamins minerals probiotics
Omega oils digestive enzymes and
antioxidants that your dog needs you
don't have to go out and buy new dog
food you just need to sprinkle rough
Greens on their dog food every day dog
owners everywhere are raving about rough
greens it supports healthy joints
improves breath boosts energy levels and
so much more head on over right now and
get a free jump start trial bag so your
dog can try it get a free jump start
trial bag deliver it straight to your
door in just a few days go to Ru
greens.com or call 844
rf123 that is rffg greens.com or call
r123 today what it means politically is
that the Democrats are now the party of
War when I was growing up 20 years ago
Republicans were the party of War
Republicans were the party of going in
and bombing the Middle East and they
often had Democrats support in those
Endeavors but the Democrats had
plausible deniability because George W
Bush was the president and they could
say oh Bush lied and he tricked us and
we actually would have opposed the war
had we known now the Democrats were the
anti-war party and the Republicans were
the pro-war party that has completely
flipped just like a lot has flipped in
politics since I was a kid when I was a
kid Republicans they were the party of
the big fat cat they were the party of
Wall Street party of Rich Uncle
pennybags Democrats were the party of
the working man that has completely
flipped now Republicans are the party of
the deplorable irredeemable Blue Collar
disgusting low class worker whatever
sort of things Hillary would call them
and Democrats they're the party of all
the Ivory Tower and the cocktail party
set and Wall Street and big business it
was a huge flip when I was a kid
Republicans were the party of free trade
and
globalization Democrats largely were the
party of economic protection and
skepticism toward free trade Bill
Clinton signed a big free trade deal but
a lot of Democrats were very skeptical
of free trade that's totally flipped now
Republicans are the party of protection
which is a return to a more traditional
Republican view the Republican party in
fact was founded on tariffs Abraham
Lincoln was a major proponent of
economic protection and tariffs
Democrats were much more in favor of
free trade things change and a lot of
people respond to this by saying that
it's hypocrisy it's not sometimes it is
hypocrisy sometimes it is but a lot of
times it is not a lot of times it is
because politics is about applying
Eternal principles to changing
circumstances and so in certain
political circumstances a little more uh
trade might be a good thing a little
loosening up of economic controls might
be a good thing in other circumstances
though it might not
be it's not always hypocrisy here um
however it is in in the case of peace
and War this does seem to be a more
significant shift than should we open up
the trade a little bit or should we
increase the tariffs a little bit this
is a recognition that the Democrats are
now the hegemonic political power in the
United States maybe that's been the case
for a long time and we just didn't
notice it but the Democrats now having a
massed power in virtually every single
sector of the country the one area where
they didn't have total hegemony was in
the military and even there you can see
the top Rass has gone totally woke Mark
mil whining about white rage and and
promoting critical race Theory as the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
they seem to have even the military as
well and with that hegemonic power
you're going to see a much more
willingness to flex that power and so on
the domestic front you're going to get
show trials like we saw with Jenna Ellis
and the the tearful forced confession
and overseas you were going to get war
war and more war and and the protesters
the the sincere protesters the ones who
are actually dissident in our country
they're going to tend to be on the right
boy what a great clip that was now hey
hey hey hey man you got to ring that
Bell subscribe to the Michael NS YouTube
channel we'll see you next time